hello
so
so
okay
so
so
[ __ ]
foreign
so
awesome
all right
foreign
bonacera good evening
it was with great sadness that today we
are
preparing to give our final farewell to
our president
europe lost a leader
democracy has lost a champion
and we all
have lost a friend
david was one of us
he was a man of great vision and great
conviction
both as a man
and as a politician
he was always capable of taking tangible
action based on the values that he
believed in
destiny has meant that he became the
president of this parliament at a
particularly difficult time for the
institution
he had to make very courageous decisions
and he fought extremely hard to make
sure that the parliament remained open
and active during the most critical
months of the pandemic
now this meant that we were able to
continue the legislative work
of the european parliament and adopt
very important legislative packages that
europe and its citizens needed
but he also wanted to send a very strong
signal of solidarity
and to do that he made the parliament's
buildings available to the most fragile
specifically
he made those available to women who
were subjected to domestic violence
and he never turned a blind eye to the
difficult challenges that he faced over
the course of two and a half years
during which he
led the parliament with dignity
as well as with clear intentions
now in his final public speech president
sasoli looked back over the course of
the
last year and said
in this year
we
heard the silence of the planet
we
were afraid but we acted
and in doing so we were able to build a
new solidarity
we fought side by side
along with those who wanted more
democracy more freedom and along with
women who request rights and
protections those who would like to be
able to have freedom of thought and we
fought with those who continue
to
ask for independent and free information
david fought courageously all the way
into the last moment
his battle against poverty injustice and
isolation will serve as an example to us
his appeal to europe to protect the most
vulnerable
and to leave in defense indifference
behind
and to help to build a new world that
respects people and nature
these lessons will continue
to resonate in this these halls for a
very long time to come
now we will all remember how um blunt
and clear he was and how he fought for
our european values as well as for his
unwavering determination to make this
world a better place
a fairer place
and a more just place
today the parliament
would like to express its condolences to
alessandro and his children giulio and
levia
and we express our sympathy to you for
his uh
untimely death
as your husband and your father now we
know what the challenges of politics and
family are and how important it was for
him to lose leave his mark
on
this area and david really did make a
difference he left his mark
once
someone said
great lives are the lives of those
that
of those individuals who hear a vocation
and answer that vocation
david
heard that
call and he answered that vocation and
with a smile at all times
last week individuals turned out in
number and essentially
they were um
either his friends or his great friends
essentially there were just these two
categories there were there was no hate
no rancor and no
adversarialism his commitment to europe
didn't come just from his approach to
politics but also via his work as a
journalist and his undying work to find
the truth
he led this institution keeping
always at
the very heart of his action the freedom
and rights of all over the course of
recent years he was able to lead us with
a
far-sighted approach and great wisdom
his words inspired us
and his actions encouraged us
his calm mildness
comforted us dear david you were a
friend a mentor and a leader
now destiny has uh
meant that you have had to leave us far
too soon when you had so much left to
achieve
but this assembly will continue to honor
everything that you have done
and we'll make sure that we bring
forward your legacy
this parliament your parliament that you
love so dearly
thanks you for everything that you have
done
on behalf of all of your colleagues
and all of those
that you met along the way
and throughout the course of this
amazing adventure would like to express
their great recognition and their final
farewell thank you david thank you
president
[Applause]
that's only 345 votes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen honorable
colleagues dear friends
i'm sure that you
all will understand my emotion in taking
up the presidency of the european
parliament
and i'm having been chosen by you to
represent the institution that more than
any other has a direct link to its
citizens
the european parliament has a duty to
represent and defend its citizens
[Music]
the european union is not an accident of
history
we are not an accident of history
we are however the children and
grandchildren of those who have found an
antidote to the nationalist degeneration
that poisoned our history
we are europeans
and that is because we all love our
countries
but nationalism that becomes ideology or
idol
idolatry produces viruses that can then
lead
to destructive conflicts
dear colleagues
europe still has much to say
if we can find a way to give that a
voice
if we can put the political debate at
this uh to the service of our citizens
and if the parliament will be able to
listen to what their wishes fears
and even what their angers are
but first and foremost what their needs
are
i am sure
that together
we will work
towards a better europe
which will only be able to be born
if we put our heart
and our ambition into this effort thank
you
[Applause]
i would like to declare the session of
the european parliament that was
interrupted on the 16th of december of
last year
resumed
and we will begin
our proceedings
with the ceremony in honor of president
david maria solid
with the funeral eulogy of mr ernie
coletta who is the secretary of the
italian democratic party and former
president of the council ministries of
italy
madam president of the european
parliament uh
dear alessandra caro julia
dear olivia
president of the french pres of the
french
republic
president of the council of the european
union
president of the european council
president of the european commission
ladies and gentlemen heads of state and
government ladies and gentlemen members
of parliament
ladies and gentlemen
the smile the eyes
the words
i should like to begin my
remarks
in remembrance of david with this
triptych
the smile his
the words
those of others
the words those who've
who of individuals who do not have a
voice
the smile his it was a special gift and
it is the first thing that comes to mind
whenever we think of david
it is the image
that
shows his strength and his placidity
his smile was an innate gift but it was
his smile that was uh his uh
state of mind and it was a smile of a
welcoming
of
coherence because the smile of david
before even just being a
innate gift it was so engaging and
captivating and it was
capable of putting all at ease it was a
smile from the from inside it was a
smile of someone who is always looking
for the good in every an event
the good in every
encounter the good in every individual
this smile it moved us it reassured us
and it gave us hope and it was always
there
all the way up through
the very last message and his very last
glimpse of alessandra giulio and
libya the eyes
eyes of others
david tried
to seek out to look at and to cross the
eyes of others these eyes that would
tell the story of the tragedies of our
era and i will i would like to remember
the words that he spoke at the nazi
massacre
the eyes of humanity without humanity
the eyes of of maltesen of sabrinitza of
syrian refugees of mothers who
have been filmed as they try to set out
for better life and drown in the course
of that
and
who will never be able to understand our
indifference david had a great gift to
look beyond things and he knew how to
not just look at appearances and to look
at substance
the words he knew how to give words to
those who did not have a voice and to
give hope to those who had no
that
did not have any hope
he was predisposed for this and this was
true throughout his uh consistent search
for a place for dialogue
and
constantly listening to others
it was of course then in europe that
david found his most uh
natural
home
because it's in europe where there is a
political project a space for dialogue
amongst people and different countries
a place to build values and solidarity
and reciprocity europe is an overture
david therefore used that as a
fundamental uh as a fundamental part of
european identity
when he said europe
is uh
has no power if it is not able to open
up
to the world outside and that was what
he tried to state when he gave a speech
at the institution
at the college of bernardines in paris
and he spoke of the
power of values he said that europe is
the power of its values and this goes
along with recovery strength and
belonging which is the motto that the
french presidency has selected for its
council presidency and this should be
the vision that is forms the foundation
of a political ambitious project over
the course of recent days
throughout italian cities there have
been there has been an outpouring of
emotion towards david his state funeral
which was
organized by president draghi and i
would like to thank him very much for
being here this afternoon and also for
his ex extraordinary service to italy
he has represented our country uh um at
an an incredibly important moment of
unity for our country
now the ceremony that took place last
friday in rome was a hymn to europe even
at in his last moments david gave us
an indication of his great legacy
on that day we saw the european flag and
we all felt very clearly that europe
isn't just a place of directives and
institutions and acronyms no europe is
first and foremost a place of its people
its souls and its hearts
yes embraces emotions and smiles
and that is precisely how i would like
to share um a reflection on something
that might be slightly uh bitter in the
atmosphere this evening but i think that
it's important for all of the women and
men that have lost someone and that feel
that pain we need to look at things
quite bluntly and not use a words for
that will be simply taken for granted
italy is in bereavement and it is also
uh
proceeding to the election of its the
president of the republic the man or
woman that will take over that rule will
succeed uh president uh sergio matarella
an exceptional president and in these
days we've we heard many people who
thought that david would have been an
excellent president of the republic in
italy
and that across the political spectrum
and
we spoke of this even just a month ago
and i looked to his smile and and
something that he said to me
remains uh very close to my heart
the lesson that i take from this is that
we have to remember that it's not in
that we can't just look at appearances
and immediacy we have to make courageous
decisions
now that choice seems obvious today
but uh
it wasn't always the case now david knew
that we had to look at the substance of
things and his constant commitment his
care his dialogue
it always went above and beyond
culturally
what
would seem obvious and his political
method showed that as well
now he
i would like to turn now to the soul of
the european project and what was uh
expressed in the manifest manifesto
event
europe is a union of diversity these
words were not just rhetorical a slogan
for david but it was really something of
substance and method david has always
worked very hard for europe that
wouldn't simply become a
typecast working extremely hard to
respect traditions and specificities now
this is something that required much
patience and
hard work
and it was important to work extremely
hard be patient
and to make sure
that uh
we do this in a peaceful way now europe
is a project of peace david knew that
and he was firmly convinced of that
specifically when he began the work that
he did in the political group called the
uh white rose a that was inspired by a
german catholic group that was opposed
to nazi fascism europe for david was a
process in history and therefore it was
going to be a long-term construction
construction site
if something for
new generations of course sustainability
to fight climate change these were not
things that were just paragraphs that
had been inserted into a speech for
europe
and
last summer for example in moto puccini
he spoke about this with young people
with a very far-sighted view with a new
vision
that would
be greener more sustainable
and a stronger europe for the future
it wouldn't be enough to work at a
national level this would need to be
done in europe and now something that
would just we we needed to look to
future generations to see how we could
make sure that the world would still be
in habitable place in a hundred years
time and as beautiful as it is today and
on that afternoon we were in the tuscan
hills and we were looking at
our situation how old we were and the
demography and we were thinking that our
children would live until they were 120
years of age and that would mean that
they would still be alive in 2150 this
is not science fiction this is the
reality and so we wondered what would
the world look like for them for their
young for the young people for the our
children for our grandchildren
all of this would depend on us and our
courage to make sure that we could
limit our generational selfishness and
above all
have a strong commitment to build a
stronger europe david knew that europe
was a place that could not exist without
democracy and rule of law because that
would have to come it would have to
exist in
it must be fought
for defended
democracy is not a gift but an
achievement that must be earned over and
over again
these beliefs were at the very core of
david's actions as president of this
parliament
during his mandate he did not only keep
the lights of european democracy on but
he also innovated it
he did so by making a choice that
changed history in 2020 when many
institutions all over the world closed
down he chose to keep this parliament
open
today
we take this choice for granted
but at that time it was a contested
divisive and therefore brave decision
with that decision shared with all of
you
david made history you
made history
by making the european parliament the
protagonist at the crucial time in our
common history that was not simply a
symbolic gesture
but foremost one of substance
in a time when it was most needed a
functioning and proactive european
parliament enabled the eu
to take up the covet crisis by using a
more communitarian
over
an inter-governmental approach
by overcoming national vetoes
and making the first concrete steps
towards a real social europe and the
europe of health
once again we had clear proof that this
chamber
all of you are the very heart of the
union's political life just imagine
what the european response to the
pandemic would have been like had the
parliament remained in lockdown
it would have been very different i'm
sure david's choice your choice
contributed to a european response based
on solidarity
in that watershed period david directed
all the energies of the european
parliament towards fighting the pandemic
when hospitals and intensive care units
risk collapse the parliament put its
drivers and cars at the disposal of
medical staff in brussels
enabling them to reach sick people at
home in strasbourg here the parliament's
premises were made available to host the
coveted screening
center for people in need
for many months in 2020 the parliament
itself opened its doors hosting women in
need and providing hot meals to the
homeless and the poorest
these
was david's idea of europe
and european institutions open to
citizens and close to their needs
bringing citizens closer to european
institutions was one of the goals david
worked for with most determination and
passion
he was one of the first supporters of
the conference on the future of europe
always ready to promote this innovative
project of participatory democracy and
to defend it from those who wanted to
water it down
just like he kept open the doors of this
parliament david aimed at opening doors
for citizens all over our continent
the participation of citizens was and is
exactly what our democracy needs now and
in the future
it is the courage to keep the doors open
to defend and support our democracy and
it is with that courage that we
all of us gathered here today should
stay committed to make the conference a
success
because this would be the best way also
to honor david's memory
as president of his part this parliament
david always worked to make citizens
voices heard
especially the weakest voices
he did so
when he fought to strengthen the social
dimension of the union he did so when he
denounced europe's reluctance to assume
his its political duties towards
developing countries on vaccines
he did so in his constant attention to
young people and students
for example in his battle to abolish the
wrongful practice of unpaid internships
in the offices of mmb's
and he did so
when he condemned the unacceptable
attitudes towards those who are fleeing
war anger and wu look at europe as a
land of hope
the truth is
that
we are not afraid of migrants but we are
afraid of poverty as you said
europe cannot be a fortress it has never
been david knew that a fortress europe
means a soulless europe doomed to lose
itself
it was to save europe that he strongly
and repeatedly called for the
construction of a common european asylum
and migration system
to finally move beyond the dublin
regulation
this is also why he visited the border
between lithuania and belarus
and the border between greece and turkey
on the everest river to call for urgent
solutions and to personally witness the
diet conditions to which men women and
children were exposed
the common thread of all this battle is
clear the european union is a union and
values that is why
we must stand firm against any
authoritarian temptation
against the attempts to silence the
press to jeopardize the independence of
the judiciary system and against the
disimmigration of minorities
as president of this parliament david
stood strongly in support of the values
we hold dear because as i said democracy
freedom and the rule of law are never up
for negotiations
david's fight for democracy freedom and
rule of law
has been an inspiration to all of us
his fight has been a beacon of hope
and it is on this world hope that i
would like to conclude
hope was the mark of david's leadership
there was hope in his smile in his highs
in his words
one of david's lessons was that hope
is not the certainty of victory but it
is an awareness that efforts for the
common good are never in vain
because they will leave a positive seed
in society
and every seed requires care
it requires time
so we have a duty
to live fully without wasting a single
moment
just like
you
did david
a random life
never
as you told friends to welcome this new
year you left an everlasting mark on
european history and on our lives
we will carry on your work
your fights will keep being our fights
we will never forget you at the audabit
[Applause]
[Applause]
i should like to now call the president
of the european council mr xiaomi shell
at the floor sir
there will be a musical interview before
just a few minutes
[Applause]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
me
so
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
yep
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Applause]
so
so
[Applause]
mercy uh president michelle was
available thank you president michelle
the floor is yours
mr president of the european parliament
these words addressed to you
dear david
we're at the beginning
of every speech given
at this rostrum over the last two and a
half years
in this temple of european democracy
where
you deployed your intelligence
and your vitality
uh for 15 years now
and in addressing
you once again
this evening
all of us
would
so much like to have had you here with
us
as president of the european parliament
you naturally inspired respect
but that respect went well beyond that
due to your office it was a respect for
you
personally warm
unpretentious
genuine
smiling
and firm
when it was necessary to manage a
meeting
we are assembled here this evening to
pay tribute to the president of the
european parliament
to a political leader
to a proud european
but first and foremost
we are saying goodbye to the man
david sesoli
is first of all a son
a father
a husband
a brother a friend
a colleague
and
i would like to say
uh solemnly and firmly
and sincerely how deep my compassion and
condolences are to his wife alessandra
his his children his mother and all his
family and
to all of those in whose lives he have
he has left
a brutal and painful gap and also in
this institution that he loved so much
a political
personality is a
woman or a man
whose
deepest nature and
life and experiences have
determined
their fate
and
a first meeting with somebody often
leaves an indelible mark and i
very well remember my first meeting with
david sesoli i was first struck by his
relaxed attitude
his generosity the way he was completely
focused on others and then this very
smiling face
this smile which was his hallmark
and in your case david the smile didn't
lie it spoke volumes about your soul
it
spoke of your convictions which were
sincere and solid it spoke of your
strength and your doubts
mario monti
found the right words the other day and
i'm going to quote him
he said
ordinary people
and politicians all saw in david sesoli
a way of participating in political life
which is not cynical which is not
machiavellian which is not devious which
is not incomprehensible which is not
self-interested
your hallmark your signature david
was summed up better than
anyone else could have done by your son
giulio in rome last friday
when he said
david sesoli
represents strong ideas
in a gentle manner
yes your convictions were strong
and they uh defined your work first of
all as a journalist to inform others is
to serve an ideal it is to help citizens
understand the world
and
thanks to that knowledge and that
understanding to exercise their rights
and freedoms in full dignity and
responsibility
this profession of journalists
you practiced with passion and elegance
which have left an indelible memory
among millions of italian
viewers and citizens
and the other source of your commitment
known to those close to you
before you
took political action
were your ideals of social justice and
solidarity
those were your colors
but more than that
they were
tangible
actions that you took for example your
decision
as president of the european parliament
to open the doors of these buildings of
this house
to help
women in particular
in need during the pandemic
i have precious memories of our
cooperation of our work together um
david
moments which
show
that kindness is a strength and it is
never a weakness
moments which show that you were
constantly concerned
to bring us together to unite us to help
us to face the future and to elicit new
ideas in the service of europe
i am convinced that ursula like me
will remember the initiative that you
took to
bring us together in january 2020 in
bazos in france
in the house of germany
in order to reflect and prepare together
for the challenges of the
european legislative term that was just
beginning
and i particularly remember the dinner
that was held in this family dining room
where you created an atmosphere mingling
complicity enthusiasm generosity
and also
the shared realization
of the power of our democratic european
values
it was that evening that i
got to know you
uh got to know your endearing
personality but very
firm when it came to uh your values and
convictions and the sense of
the need for compromise to forge
european unity and these are qualities
that were revealed
as extremely
useful just a few months later when we
had to mobilize to adopt the budget and
the european recovery plan
together with you also we had to face
the reality of brexit
and it was
together at a press conference in
brussels that we decided to symbolically
mark the day of brexit by stating our
shared determination to bring forward
the european project in the service of
all our fellow citizens
and today
we can recognize
that it wasn't very easy to transform
such a setback into a moment of optimism
but david sesoli
found the right words
passionate words
to defend the european project
words that came from the heart
words that captivated the audience and
words that
breathe new life new heart
lift the spirits and
inspire you to go further and
better
you said david and you were right that
if authoritarian powers are attacking
europe or criticizing europe it's
because they are afraid of our democracy
our freedoms and our values because if
what we do in europe works here then it
can work elsewhere in the world european
values of freedom and democracy are
existential threats to autocrats
throughout the world and i saw that day
how
this smiling kindly
david sesoli could turn into a
passionate orator
a genuine lion in the service of
democracy
and also i cannot forget
other moments some public some more
private where david defended his
messages and those of the european
parliament without fear of who he might
offend or or whose opinions he might
contradict um
amongst the heads of state and
government for example at the conference
in bled in slovenia last september where
following the fall of kabul
causing a stir in the front row of the
room you
didn't mince your words in criticizing
the governments who you felt were too
reluctant when it came to
helping migrants
and that's where i saw
david sesoli with its smile but also
with a piercing eye combative without
concession
and just a month ago
on the 16th of december
we were at the same table in the
european council
and uh
according to tradition and with your
usual uh
kindness and warmth you opened uh
the the meeting presenting the positions
of the european parliament
and i am
touched and moved now when i remember
this moment and i reread what you said
because in fact you said
that you wanted to go beyond
the questions of
current events to talk about renewing
the entire european project
and today i see this is a kind of
political uh testament that you have
left us because you talked of a new
project of hope for europe
a project
that
could represent our union our values and
our civilization
and specifically you suggested we
propose that the 9th of may should be
the occasion of an
event
that would bear witness to our
attachment to this project
the video are leaving us
and it's now up to us
to take on that commitment with which
you uh concluded and i quote you again
it's now up to us to translate these
visions into action so that europe can
serve all europeans for europe to take
its true place dear david you did your
part
and
then some for europe uh to come into its
own
you
held your own as a man as a citizen as
a committed uh
political leader
so you're leaving us david
but a part of you remains in each of us
we are inspired by your example
thank you mr president thank you david
rest in peace
[Applause]
thank you i'd like to now call president
macron
for his speech
[Music]
madam president of the european
parliament
president of the european council
ladies and gentlemen
heads of state and government ladies and
gentlemen members of the european
parliament
dear alessandra dia
julio and did libya
ladies and gentlemen
less than two months ago in this very
chamber
we were paying tribute
with
david cesari by our side to another
great figure of europe
who had left us
nobody
could then have imagined
that
he would so soon disappear
with the same conviction with the same
drive
he expressed
himself
and he gave voice to everything that was
the european adventure and it is with
great emotion that i wished to remember
a man of rare kindness
whose smile
whose ideals and whose vision were big
enough for a whole continent
it is with the greatest admiration too
for a brilliant career
which saw him progress from journalism
studies
to the anchor of the 8pm italian news
and
right to this chamber
i also wish to pay tribute to his
exemplary political trajectory with its
three periods sitting in this house
he who was elected to the benches of
parliament in 2009
in so doing he started
and turned a page on journalism starting
a new chapter in his life writing in the
incapability engagement
whose reach stretched beyond the borders
of italy
finally it is with a sense of debt
a debt we owe him for his work in
building europe
all these building blocks that he added
to our edifice here today as a master
builder and all those he cut and shaped
for tomorrow when he was elected vice
president in 2014 he quickly set the
tone and the tempo
as the man in charge of the budget he
held our common purse strings
with discernment and efficacy
and with the same sense of openness
i would ask you to think back
he was the person responsible for the
dialogue with the mediterranean
countries and the middle east and he
opened wide the window of europe towards
the south and did so with a talent that
reminded you he too was the son of the
mediterranean
he also managed to support dialogue
between our union and the west and
western
balkans creating new tiny ties with
northern macedonia and albania places he
went to on many occasions an attentive
and effective emissary
many of those
events have been recalled today
ambition heart and ambition these words
were the siren calls of his investiture
speech in 2019 heart and ambition
he needed both of these
more than any other president of the
parliament no doubt whose presidency was
struck after barely six months
by this pandemic which is still
curtailing our lives he who was
concerned until the end but the sound
running of your plenary session which is
being held here this week even at the
height of the crisis making the painful
choice to go into lockdown here in
brussels far from his long one loved
ones to devote himself footage to the
task he was not going to be dictated to
in his responses by panic but was going
to be expressing the voice of prudence
and reason
and the members are
recognized that
he
made the choice to stay open
to work to organize very quickly he also
managed to organize the
uh buildings in the european parliament
both in strasbourg and brussels to
prepare meals for the families that were
in need for setting up a testing center
for covert 19 and for victims female
victims of violence
showing to europe a message that was one
of humanity the europe after all that he
defended was the europa solidarity
solidarity between its citizens and
between its members the europe that he
defended is strong
it has force in unity
he was a person who brought order and
peace to this hemicycle at the same time
he met ideas head on
he didn't confront the people
he was a builder of bridges capable of
bringing together speakers who seemed
far apart in language cultural character
it was this personal gift that allowed
him to break down people's reticence and
to forge consensus
it was with this great talent that he
managed to get
rise to the challenge of the crisis
showing that the principles
that he held were up to the test and
were not just down to the sovereignty of
the state but also in collective
sovereignty our sovereignty in this
third millennium who can do without
europe but despite all the difficulties
he managed to get a majority together
and he managed to
create the foundations for common debt a
europe that was really showing a united
front and which was writing its destiny
together
he never lost view of the importance of
defending the rule of law in europe in
this continent and elsewhere
it is something that he pursued
throughout his term in office just as he
looked out for climate challenges and
migratory challenges and was always
fighting for a new common pact
with others he also
brought
important
uh underpinnings to the conference of
the
future of europe faithful that his
conception of a more embodied europe
with roots from the very base to the
very top close to its citizens in his
speech in the night to may 2021 i
remember
how he talked about his faith in
efficiency and in democracy
in the face of authoritarian temptation
it is only democracy that can protect
our individual
liberty and collective liberty and human
dignity peace and security as well as
social progress
he grew up in florence and studied in
rome
and he
brought great honour on these two
flamboyant capitals of european humanism
with his profound sense of the dignity
of mankind strengthened once again by
its christian ideals
i bow my head before him and before his
family
i wish to express my most profound
condolences
and
those that went along the road with him
in this
battle
we are with you we are with the italian
people dear mario with all the members
of this house present
and his team both here and far away and
the staff of the european parliament who
all of them i know were so fond of him
this is the europe that he held the
rudder through the storm
of this crisis setting
uh
a line for the future a stronger and
more united future
and a little bit of him will remain in
perpetuity through it
and we will pursue that
because the european flame that we
continue to hold high
and his final speech on the 16th of
december
where he talked about a europe that
could innovate protect and radiate
is one that we recall
so we all
can remember
the softness of his smile
we all remember the determination
he had an almost metallic gaze
this strength
particularly when he was talking about
europe and its values
and the humility
it became him so well and yet it's so
rare in this world
this humility
this
alloy of respect for other people
and
a desire not to speak too much of
himself
it is these
triumphs that we remember
this combination of softness
humility
the face
of a european of great good faith
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much we now uh pass on to
speeches by the presidents of the
different political groups starting with
miss iracia garcia perez on behalf of
the s d group
alessandra
alessandra
giulio olivia
ladies and gentlemen
jacques de laure
used to say that europe lacked a soul
well david sasoli embodied precisely
this soul of europe
this is perhaps the most difficult
speech
the most painful
to give because we haven't only lost a
president a great president we have lost
a colleague a friend
and europe has lost an exemplary
politician
seeing politics as serving the common
good as a collective effort to improve
people's lives and all this always with
his smile with a kindly look in his eye
and a sincere desire to build bridges to
move forward together without leaving
anyone behind and above all concerning
himself with the most vulnerable with
those who need
politics more than anybody else in order
to get by because the value of the
individual
their dignity is the measure of our
policies david used to say
in his inaugural speech in this very
chamber at the beginning of his
presidency he enumerated the founding
values of our union freedom dignity
solidarity that we must work towards
both within europe and beyond
and this is what he dedicated his life
to to this noble aim and to his family
and to his friends during the last two
and a half years he devoted himself
entirely to this house which is the
house of european democracy
he had to face the worst crisis that
this continent has known since the
second world war we have to thank him
for his commitment to ensuring that this
parliament could remain open and
operational although it meant that he
had to leave behind his family and stand
here at his post in the most difficult
times
in very difficult circumstances
we learned to work together
always
with this smile and this extended hand
which
really always made everything much
easier
he raised the voice of this parliament
to call for a european response of
solitarity of solidarity with a recovery
fund financed
jointly in order to respond to the needs
of europe but he never forgot either the
most urgent needs when everything was
closed in the worst moments of lockdown
i'm sure you'll remember he set up a
social canteen in this parliament and a
reception center for women
in this building who had been victims of
gender-based violence and in his last
video message he reminded us once again
of our obligation to take care of the
most vulnerable in society and that
social protection is the hallmark of
europe
many people have fond memories of david
because
david won people's affection
from
all political groups and from all
corners of europe the marks of affection
are pouring in for
the loss of a good man a committed man a
passionate european who was able uh to
dialogue and at the same time to hold
true to his principles of freedom
democracy and solidarity so perhaps the
best tribute that we can pay him today
is to continue with his legacy to build
social europe
and to create
a migration policy that puts people at
the center
to work together
to bring about the europe that he
devoted his life to
as you know david was also a very
generous person and so today
i'm going to ask him one last favor
i would like to borrow from him a little
of that christian faith that he held
and that i lack
to think that
from wherever he is now
he can see the affection and respect in
which we all hold him
dear friend dear president
you will always stay with us in our
hearts
[Applause]
thank you very much miss garcia perez
and now i invite manfred berber
president of the epp group to take the
floor
the entire european parliament pays
tribute to president to our president
david sassooni
we all were heartbroken by the news of
his death it was a shock
with his kindness his values
european vocation the seriousness and
the spirit of
compassion for helping those in need
david sasoli
is and was a great european we owe him a
lot
our thoughts are first of all with his
family his wife alessandro alessandra
victorini and his two children libya and
julian
personally
i lose a friend
he was a role model of
professional ethics in both journalism
and politics far from loudness and
dirty tactics indeed david sassoli will
be remembered as a bridge builder
inspired by the idea
of serving his community
both his communication style and his
political culture were inspired by the
values of tolerance and solidarity
i loved to work with david david was a
real bridge builder
his roots laid in the social
catholicism and he was a committed
social democrat who not only listened to
other opinions
but was able to build
up on these different opinions common
solutions to build up riches
with his death the european parliament
loses a
passionate politician
a thoughtful leader
and a great personality
home was italy but his destiny was
europe
for example he was in berlin when the
wall fell
for him the fall of the berlin wall was
a european event the founding episode of
today's europe which made
the east west north and south of europe
stronger together
this togetherness and the unity of all
europeans
was his approach
to lead our european parliament
david sassoli repeatedly affirmed that
young people want a different and more
united europe he also reiterated his
firm belief in the future of europe
especially in the inauguration of the
conference for the future of europe of
which he is also one of the leading
architects and i quote him
i am personally convinced
that the awareness of our unity and the
common destiny is shared by a majority
of citizens and decision makers
let us overcome our differences and work
together
by respecting our diverse diversity
to lay the foundation for a new social
democratic and european contract let us
make a stronger more resilient more
democratic and more united europe
let us all work together to ensure that
his legacy sees the light
thank you very much for all david
rest in peace
thank you very much and now on behalf of
the renew group i invite mr dutch and
charles to take the floor
first and foremost i should like to
thank my colleague stefan sojourney
who yielded the floor to me to speak on
behalf of my group
i'd like to turn to the family to david
to all of you
i was lucky enough to know david and
work with him
for more than two years
above and beyond all of the words that
we can say about his political
work
and
the combat that he led to help people
what
really assisted me in working with david
was how incredibly openhearted he was
that's not something that necessarily
comes naturally in
our area of work and it's not
necessarily what we look for first and
foremost but when we begin to open our
hearts
we can see that
there are many solutions to be found
david
loved people and people love david
i had the opportunity to feel that just
a few days ago in rome i spent the
weekend in rome
after the funeral and i walked around
the streets of rome at that time and i
would hear people
next to me in restaurants on the streets
people would hold david's picture up
or they would look to the pictures that
had been distributed by the democratic
party in italy across rome and they
would
speak about him
because in his journalistic work
david did that work because he loved
people and he loved to be able to
transmit things to people he did this
extremely sincerely and it's perhaps one
of the reasons that he is so beloved as
a journalist
and i'm sure that he
also turned to politics because he
wanted to be able to bring about even
more good
in a tangible way and so what he felt
was that he needed to go into politics
for that reason
and what i felt when throughout the
course of my work with him
you'll know of course that we had very
little time to work together under
normal conditions because the
pandemic
emerged on
only six months later and it was david
who kept the institution
open he was extremely clear and
extremely
firm on that point
but above and beyond that responsibility
that he held had and felt as the
president he never forgot
the people
because we weren't in the buildings
he made the decision to open up the
parliament's buildings to
women to people
and to
make the
vehicles that the parliament has at its
disposable available to those who would
need them
and he did this in that
openheartedness and that open-mindedness
and that humanism that
he experienced that he lived
and not something that he just paid lip
service to but rather something that he
absolutely did through his actions we
all i believe have very much to learn
from these types of people who are sent
to us
it's somewhat that
spirit of an angel that lives amongst us
amongst the living
and through them
in life
we
understand that even when we have great
responsibility within the institutions
we have to remain
humane with an open heart
and naturally of course we're going to
use our minds very much to think but
often the best decisions are taken
through the heart and there is much to
be learned from working through the
heart the world around him
and
has become better because of that
that is what david gave me over the
course of the more than two years that i
worked with him
i also had the opportunity to really
get a feel for how authentic he was
through the way that he
acted and did
and specifically throughout the words
that julio and levia
spoke of their father
i understood through what they said
that their father was really able to
transmit that spirit to them as well in
an extremely natural way
and he did that
through his example in the way that he
lived all the way through to his last
days
madam my sincere condolences julian
olivia
my deepest sympathies
and
also lorenzo magneli
was with him day and night
over the course of his work here within
the european parliament thank you
merci and now i invite ska keller to
take the floor on behalf of the green
group
dear presidents
dear colleagues and dear family of david
last week we have not only lost a
political leader we have also lost a
member of our european family
and as it always is with family members
they leave a painful void
a void that will be felt in this
parliament for a very long time
president sasoli was a committed
heartfelt pro-european
he carried a deep conviction that
europe's future could only be ensured by
working together
by overcoming the borders of the past
he leaves us a big legacy and it is up
to us now to continue on this path
his conviction and passion for europe is
our guidance for the future
in his political life president sasoli
could always rely on the power of the
better argument he was a man of
political discussions striving to change
people's minds and convictions with the
power of words
and thanks to his visions
humor and his compassion he was able to
connect with people and build lasting
ties
in the current political climate that is
so often shaped by polarization and
antagonism
he was able to build bridges and bring
people together
he was in that sense
a politician of the best kind
and the best ambassador for our
democratic house
president sasoli and i saw eye to eye on
many big challenges that our continent
is facing today be it on climate change
on the need for truly social europe
it was however his continuous battle
against the humanitarian disaster of
people suffering and dying at eu borders
that brought us together the most
i will always honor david for his very
clear words and deeply human approach
he impressed me as he did not shy away
when the call for rescuing people at sea
was far from popular while he was
convinced it is a human duty
and dear members of this house we have
lost a most distinguished colleague and
a great european politician
my deeply felt condolences go to the
family of david who has lost so much
word mahou has lost so much more
davitza soli president of the european
parliament will be missed deeply and he
will not be forgotten thank you
[Applause]
now i should like to give the floor to
mark ozani who is the leader of the id
group
i think today
we are seeing a clear example
that there is much respect and pain for
the loss of the institutional
character of david sasoli and that
should mean that we should
unite around a common residence that
goes across the political spectrum and
beyond the political party that david
was a part of
the political vision of the group that i
represent as you know is not one that
necessarily has affinities with the
group that david was a part of we
haven't always had the respectful
acknowledgement that individuals like
him
a kind cultured individual
that would believe in the his ideas with
authentic authentic passion and then
move them forward seriously
they definitely
pay great tribute to politics as a whole
there has been so much affection towards
him
and there's been a sin serious a
farewell on behalf of all of the
institutions during the state funeral in
rome i think that this expresses better
than any individual word can
the man that cecily was and what he left
within all of us
not just within his uh amongst his loved
ones and that of course we would like to
send our deepest sympathies to yet again
today
just a few weeks ago in december
as is often the case
we had the opportunity to meet and to
exchange a few opinions here in
strasbourg
that was during the
last plenary session of the year 2021
and then just a few days later during
the holidays um the christmas holiday we
had the opportunity to wish each other a
happy new year
cesoli and i exchanged with great
cordial cordialness and we had
reciprocal respect and i can still
remember for example his
eyes that
showed a smile that he had an extremely
uh simple approach in his way to
interact with anyone in within the
confines of this house
now we know that he had a high profile
position
and he was extremely dedicated to that
dedicated in a way
as the president of the european
parliament he showed courageously and
tangible tangibly precisely what
he could achieve all the way through
till his last days
godspeed david we hope that your smile
will be an inspiration for all of us for
a long time to come thank you
grazia
thank you i should now like to give the
floor to rafael fito who is the
co-leader of the ecr group
president
president authorities colleagues
members of david's family
the premature death of david so solely
has left a void in all of us
at the same time
it leaves us a memory that all of those
who knew him will carry along with them
he was kind and respectful of all of
those that he dealt with despite and
irregardless of the role that they
held
president sasoli carried out his role
with a tremendous
competence and he looked to our citizens
he had institutional know-how and he
made sure that the parliament was open
even during the pandemic
that showed just how dedicated he was in
the role that he carried out even during
the course of his illness
that he
experienced with great dignity and that
showed extremely clearly that the
characteristic that
soli had
was one that should be an example to all
now the
principal virtue that he had was that he
was able to
organize and make the european
parliament's work operational despite
all of the challenges and that shows
how dense and deep his competence was
for this institution now it's not a
mystery whatsoever
sasoli had very different political
positions from our group
for example in terms of the reform of
the european union and in at times we
had heated debates with him at the same
time time that never prevented us over
the course of years within this chamber
but also in the conference of the
presidents we were able to have
constructive debates that were
respectful of all positions and that
showed his intelligence as well as his
far-sightedness and his political
responsibility now david was not just
the president of this parliament
throughout the course of his time here
he was he became first and foremost a
friend we had different political
positions but this was never a limit to
our ability to strengthen our personal
relationship
and this was indeed consolidated and it
grew over the course of time even over
the course of recent days we spoke to
each other regularly and we even had a
chance to reiterate our feelings our
friendship and
our um respect for each other there were
a number of different uh
uh um events that took place that i
would love to give you all of them that
kept that will keep him in my heart
for all for example he
had a great passion a great irony
sarcasm a great smile that many have
made reference to he was always prepared
to listen to us and to give very useful
advice to us
i think it's also important on behalf of
the
conservatives group
to recall
and
to send the deepest sympathies first and
foremost the family
um alessandra and the children giulio
and libya to the political community of
the democratic party and the
socialists and democrats as well as to
his staff that i had the opportunity to
work with and i did indeed appreciate
the quality of their work
now he was a political adversary but
despite
that fact we know that his role as a
parliament president of this parliament
has come to a conclusion but we know
that he has laid the groundwork for
future challenges and his work has been
extremely useful for that now we had
differing opinions for example that
really uh
broadened the richness of our debates
and his political commitment these are
the main lessons that i think this
chamber and that italian politics should
take away from the life of david sasoli
and continue to learn from them in
upcoming years
european politics of course but politics
as a whole and all of us should remember
an excellent interlocutor that was
respectful and extremely serious thank
you
grazie
and now on behalf of the left group i
invite martin shildown to take the floor
dear family and loved ones of david dear
colleagues let me start on a more
personal note
the ceremony today is very moving
because we are not only commemorating
our president of the european parliament
david maria sasoli
we are also commemorating a colleague
and
a friend whose optimism openness and
willful cooperation will be
deeply missed
david's entire work has been based
on a deep-rooted humane perspective on
politics and society
as president of this parliament
that many consider the beating heart of
european democracy
david set out
to strengthen democratic procedures and
the rights of the european parliament
and his political ambitions were always
driven by the deepest respects for
democracy
but he did not do that for the sake of
his role or for the sake of this
institution alone
he did it first and foremost for
european citizens
whose voice
he wanted to be heard
whose aspirations and demands he wanted
to see realized by and through this
very parliament
and from the very start of his
presidency
he reminded us relentlessly
that democracy cannot be taken for
granted
and that democracy
is under attack every day and that it
has to be defended every day
already in his first speech as president
and we saw that earlier today
he expressed his conviction that
european integration and european
democracy have their roots also in the
destruction devastation of europe caused
by nationalism and fascism
european democracy and
anti-fascism are two sides and were two
sides for david of the same coin
this week
the european parliament is about to
elect
its new leadership dear colleagues
the best way to commemorate david sasoli
is to follow his legacy
and to ensure that all democratic voices
are heard with the same respect in this
institution now and in the future
thank you and favel david
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much
dear presidents dear loved ones of
president sasoli colleagues i will now
interrupt the session so that we
continue with our work but thank you
very very much for being here thank you
have a good evening
okay
good